now returning to a story we've covered
extensively over the past week the
ongoing military lockdown in
indian administered kashmir new delhi
revoked the autonomy of the disputed
region on monday prompting a stern
response from neighbouring pakistan
sarah bin javed joins us now live from
muzaffarabad with the
foreign minister of pakistan mahmoud
quraishi
thanks sami we are with the foreign
minister who's just arrived
in muzafrabat on the pakistani side of
kashmir
where he is going to be spending eid
with kashmiris both who live here and
those who have been displaced
from the indian side mr croatia thank
you very much for being with us
you've just returned from china as
pakistan's offensive
diplomatically continues what did you
achieve and are you satisfied that the
international community uh understands
pakistan's point of view
well we have to project our point of
view and the
decision taken by the national security
committee
which was endorsed by the cabinet and
obviously demanded by
the joint session of parliament was that
we should go to the security council
and to as a first step uh
i thought it was necessary to consult
with our
ally uh someone who stood with pakistan
consistently and is one of the p5
members that's china
so i went with the delegation
to meet with the chinese leadership
met the state councillor for minister
and
presented our point of view to him
and the chinese government and i have
come back
with satisfaction that if they
completely understand
and endorse our point of view they've
considered
the indian uh action as unilateral
uh unlawful uh and they feel
that the matter should be resolved under
the u.n charter
and uh according to the applicable
security council resolutions so they
have
endorsed our point of view they are
equally concerned
about the peace and security of the
region
this action has undermined peace and
security
of the region there are concerns of
human rights violations
on the inside of kashmir
you have seen this curfew there is a
communication
blackout journalists are not being
allowed in
so the news is not filtering out there's
absolute
confusion uncertainty one is hearing a
hearing of food shortages
one is hearing of non-availability of
medicines
i do not know tomorrow is eid which is a
very important day for muslims
whether they will lift the curfew i
demand that the
indian authorities lift a curfew
and let the muslims uh perform
their prayers and do the sacrifice that
they are supposed to do mreshi the
international response to this according
to many international observers has been
muted at best the united nation
secretary general urged
both sides to refrain from changing the
status of kashmir
the emirati ambassador went out and said
that it is an internal matter
for the indian government so is the
pakistani government running out of
options diplomatically
to try and come to some sort of a
solution not at all i think the uh
options are just beginning in fact uh
india by being obstinate
and not uh accepting pakistan's
offer of a bilateral engagement
to resolve this issue uh through
peaceful negotiations
miscalculated and i think this decision
of theirs
of revoking uh and bringing in the
change
constitutional change which has
materially affected
uh the status of uh uh
kashmir has
given an opportunity uh to pakistan in
my view
to take the case to the security council
because it is
already on the agenda it's a pending
agenda item
on the security council and we expect
and we will argue that this step has
uh there are concerns vis-a-vis peace
and security
uh in south asia and we are concerned
about the
genocide that we feel can take place
perhaps is taking place right now
because we have
no idea what's going on uh in the indian
occupied kashmir right now
when they lifted the curfew for a few
hours you saw
thousands of people protesting on the
streets
so it's an evolving situation pakistan
is watching the situation carefully
and so is the world the statement of the
secretary general of the u.n is a very
balanced and very correct statement he
has said
that this issue should be resolved under
the u.n charter and
applicable security council resolutions
i think that's a very
encouraging statement the support
offered to pakistan by china
that they are with us all the way
is very encouraging and uh prime
minister mahad khan
is reaching out to world leaders uh i'm
contacting
different foreign ministers uh for
example i spoke to the
kuwaiti foreign minister this morning uh
he was very supportive
uh very encouraging so it is building
up in many countries european countries
when i spoke to the
high representative of the european
union
uh fredericka mogherini she was
concerned
on the uh humanitarian issue
you know the the human rights violations
the reports that they are getting from
uh
from from you know from people all over
are alarming
they are alarming and they're concerned
about it but there's also concern on the
pakistani side as well i've spent the
day at the line of control talking to
ordinary kashmiris
who feel that pakistan perhaps has not
done
enough uh that is something that was
shared on the parliament's floor by the
opposition
as well where the prime minister said
that you know pakistan cannot go to war
how would you if you've just taken the
decision to come and spend either with
them
how what would you tell them which will
satisfy them that pakistan is doing all
it can
or for the kashmir to begin with why am
i here
to give a message of solidarity
i represent the government of pakistan
and i am here with the permission of the
prime minister of pakistan
i discussed it with him last night and
he said by all means you must go
and show solidarity he himself is coming
to muzaffarabad
to address the uh the assembly on the
14th of august
we have declared uh 14th of august
which is our independence day to be a
day
of uh solidarity uh with uh with the
kashmiris on both sides of the loc
and we've announced the 15th of august
is going to be a black day
observed by kashmiris and pakistanis
all over the world in every capital
there will be
a standing shoulder to shoulder
with their kashmiri brothers and sisters
what are your biggest fears and what is
the hope that you have
that pakistan's version of events
pakistan's
what pakistan's point of view is is
going to be heard and it will prevail
my biggest fear is the
the genocide that can
take place on the inside of cash which
we have no evidences yet
well open up open up
you were here did anybody stop you you
went to the loc you met people you're
interviewing people
will they allow you there vic why don't
you attempt
and try after having been here
go and make a request to the indian side
and let them allow you to go to sri
nagar
to meet the leadership over there will
they allow you i doubt it
so we have nothing to fair we have
nothing to hide
and uh i think pakistan has a solid
case and we're going to articulate that
case we're going to put the case in
front of the world community
international community and we are
concerned about
the uh violations that are taking place
because today in india
you have a regime which has the fascist
mentality
you know that nazi approach that they
have
is that rss mentality
you know this is a political wing of the
rss
and that is of great concern uh
to pakistan innocent people
being attacked killed raped
maimed and through the pellet guns you
know losing eyesight
what is going to be what is your biggest
fear is i ask you because
the world is watching closely that two
nuclear armed rivals
are now in the battle for words uh where
they
don't you've cut off well almost uh cut
off diplomatic relations you're
downgraded to the maximum level
you've cut off trade responsible for
that so
is it who is responsible for that my
question is is there
a fear that this could lead to an
escalation where
it would go to a point of no return well
we are fearing
that to divert world attention
from the atrocities that are being
committed uh
in indian occupied cashmere the indians
might undertake a false
flag operation and then turn
uh sort of a twist events and distort
uh events and say ha you know this was
a cross border terrorism you know
the pulwama ii that staged drama that
they did
in february they would try and create uh
some kind of a
situation to divert uh
world attention and that is why we are
saying
that on that pre-text they might do
something stupid
what they have done already that was a
stupid move now
it's a rash move in our view and uh
we're going to tell the world it's it's
a responsibility you know
yes you said yes there are two nuclear
armed states
uh and we think uh a war is not a
solution
uh it's mutual suicide that's never been
an option
our response even in february was
defensive in nature we were not
aggressive
so we are going to articulate
our case diplomatically
politically and we will look at the
legal options
uh we will see besides the security
council what options do we have
what are those options because people
have been talking about people have been
talking about pakistan stepping up its
military presence on the line of control
stopping air space what are those
options that you're saying incorrect
we have not we have not stopped airspace
let me qualify that let me clarify that
we have not they are in a habit of
generating
uh fake news uh and and they you know
they take advantage of that
but we have not uh we have not
uh are you going to sorry are you going
to
we haven't taken that decision yet but
it depends on
how they react and how they behave and
what is their attitude
uh what we are saying is we have a case
that case is pending the security
council they have rejected
they have rejected mediation they have
rejected third party facilitation
and they are also uh
shy of a bilateral interaction
and on top of that they are changing the
status
of jammu and kashmir which is a disputed
territory internationally recognized
dispute
so what do we do the only rational
reasonable uh option with pakistan was
go
to the security council and tell the
security council
it is their responsibility it's on their
agenda
it's a pending item and peace and
security is their prime responsibility
mr qureshi thank you very much for being
with us uh well there you have it that
was the
foreign minister of pakistan china with
kirishi speaking to us telling us that
pakistan believes
in a diplomatic solution out of this
crisis pakistan is going to
employ all of its resources uh to find
uh support for its version of events
and is going to be going to the security
council soon all right great interview
there thanks so much summer benjamin